george floyd square has transformed from
crime scene to memorial
to a somber site of celebration look
there's a feeling of hope
that there was a big turn yesterday by
you know by the murder verdict we just
came back to celebrate
take some time out to you know
if you grasp the moment grasp what's
been happening these last couple of
months saying no just
give us our relief you know that's
really what it is man it's our relief
many who've been demonstrating for 11
months felt buoyed further by the
announcement on wednesday that the u.s
justice department has launched a
sweeping investigation into whether the
minneapolis police department engages in
discriminatory or unconstitutional
practices
building trust between community and law
enforcement will take time
and effort by all of us
but we undertake this task with
determination
and urgency knowing that change
cannot wait on capitol hill a bill named
after george floyd would ban
racial profiling in police choke holds
we must remain diligent in our efforts
to bring meaningful change
to police departments across the country
to reform practices and training
and the legal protections that grant too
great a shield to police officers guilty
of misconduct
here where floyd spent his last moments
of life many said the verdict against
former minneapolis police officer derek
chauvin
is a start the people we've talked to
here at the site of george floyd's
murder say this movement
isn't over with the conviction of derek
chovin or even with the other officers
involved they say it will
end when they no longer have to say that
black lives matter
for the floyd family knowing that
chauvin won't get away with using his
badge to justify murder brings a
long-awaited release
i feel better i feel relieved i
actually went to sleep for like five
hours
last night and that was that was great
and that
offers hope and perhaps change to the
next generation of black americans
john hendren al jazeera minneapolis